so here's a question I get quite a lot
how do I find my why well there are many
ways to find it I even wrote a book
called find your why to help people find
it but here's a really fun little
exercise that anyone can do called the
friends exercise don't do this with a
spouse don't do this with a family
member those relationships are too close
do it with a best friend and ask them
the simple question why are we friends
and they're going to start by describing
you I don't know they're gonna say
you're always there for me I can trust
you and you have to play Devil's
Advocate good you say that's just the
definition of a friend what specifically
is it about me
that I know you'd be there for me no
matter what and eventually they'll start
describing themselves and I got
goosebumps in fact I'm getting them
right now because what they're doing is
articulating the value you have in their
lives and you will have an emotional
response you'll either get goosebumps or
you'll well up and this is when you know
you're in the Wheelhouse you're in the
ballpark for what your why is